[MUSIC]
Now you're mine.
No escape this time.
Do you feel that chill.
Running up your spine.
Don't look twice.
I won't play nice.
It's finally time for you.
To pay the price.
Walk with me.
Through the woods.
You'll see.
A lovely playground.
For you and me.
You're trapped this time.
I'm in your mind.
We're not so different.
You and I.
I chased you through hallways.
And forests.
And crawlways.
Your body is breaking.
And soon you'll be mine.
Go back to the school.
Where my children play.
Now be a good boy.
Come right this way.
Do you think you've.
Been through hell.
Just wait til you're locked.
Inside my cell.
You can pray.
Even pray to the pope.
Just pray that you don't.
Drop the soap.
[MUSIC]
[NOISE].
What!
[MUSIC]